[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie pour
aujourd'hui je reçois avec grand plaisir
une historienne elle s'appelle Fanny
cosendet elle est spécialiste en
monarchie de l'Ancien Régime Fanny
causandev bonjour bonjour Merci d'être
sur notre plateau on va parler d'un
livre absolument passionnant qui est
sorti en mèche et Fayard qui s'appelle
reine des mer famille et politique de la
France d'anciens régime voilà et à mon
oubliés on va dire que pour ceux qui
veulent vous voir en vrai en chair et en
os vous serez au salon histoire de lire
à Versailles les 19 et 20 novembre qui
se trouve ce salon se trouve à l'hôtel
de ville à la mairie voilà c'est ça
c'est dit ça c'est dit alors donc vous
vous êtes historienne vous travaillez
actuellement comme directrice d'études à
le
Hess École des hautes études sciences
sociales
et vous avez commis plusieurs ouvrages à
savoir déjà votre thèse qui était la
reine de symboles et pouvoir chez
Gallimard et après un autre ouvrage le
rang précédent s'est hiérarchique dans
la France et ancien régime Gallimard
donc vraiment c'est votre truc quoi vous
êtes à fond et heureusement et grâce à
ça ce livre est vraiment passionnant on
découvre alors comment dire
qu'elle a été votre motivation première
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit
alors la question c'était de savoir
finalement quel était la part de la de
l'affection maternelle par rapport aux
enfants et surtout la part des enjeux
politiques qui sont derrière ça et ce
qui m'intéressait c'était de développer
précisément les enjeux politiques qui
déterminent pratiquement toutes les
relations des mères des reines avec
leurs enfants et des rois d'accord parce
qu'on parle d'un petit micro-cosme
finalement tout petit peu de personnes
ne sont bleues de ce pays européen qui
sont tous plus ou moins cousins et qui
et donc ils ont besoin de alors la femme
en soi on est on est tout en haut du
pouvoir on parle des reines ou des
princesses d'accord c'est ce dont vous
parlez d'ailleurs
elle a quoi elle a trois fonctions en
schématisant oui alors non en fait oui
c'est ça dans le cadre de la monarchie
française on attend d'elle qu'elle soit
mère c'est-à-dire qu'elle a sur la
proclamation dy
qu'elle soit l'épouse royale et donc la
représentation de la majesté dans les
cérémonies monarchiques et même au
quotidien à la cour à la Maison de la
reine etc et qu'elle assure aussi la
stabilité politique dans les moments de
régence c'est-à-dire quand le roi
succède et qu'il a pas l'âge de monter
de de d'assurer son pouvoir d'accord
donc là on a l'exemple par exemple de
Louis XV tout simplement qui a 4 ans et
demi quand son arrière
oui pardon Louis XV il a 4 ans et demi
quand oui c'est ça
et sa mère
sur la Régence
bon allez revenons à nos moutons donc
c'est c'est l'affection justement est-ce
qu'il peut y en avoir parce que vous
remettez bien les choses vraiment dans
leur contexte la façon complètement
concrète il se trouve que déjà il faut
il faut être enceinte tout de suite tout
de suite le plus vite possible on sait
que les femmes peuvent mourir en couche
très très fréquemment les bébés peuvent
mourir aussi très jeunes même les
enfants jusqu'à je sais pas 15 ans ils
sont restés fragiles et et puis dès que
l'enfant naît qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
l'enlève à sa mère
effectivement
dès la naissance les enfants sont
retirés à la mer pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord pour des questions
profilactiques c'est qu'on les éloigne
de la cour ou la presse les conditions
d'hygiène etc sont pas terribles pour
les petits et en même temps il peut y
avoir 200 personnes lors de
l'accouchement au moment de la couche
mais juste après on a quand même on
l'isole on l'isole on fait au moment de
la couche pas il y a du monde parce
qu'il s'agit de montrer en fait que
effectivement c'est bien le fils de la
reine si j'ose dire et qu'il y a pas
substitution d'enfants c'est toujours
l'enjeu de la de la succès faut des
témoins oculaires exactement mais après
on le retire et on lui retire aussi
parce que ça permet à la reine d'être un
nouveau féconde beaucoup plus rapidement
mais également pour des questions
profilactiques donc les enfants partent
si on prend un mari de Médicis ou c'est
très bien informé les enfants au bout
d'un mois elle les voit une fois par
jour à peu près le premier mois après
oui ou même pas et puis après ils sont
envoyés bah Saint-Germain ou ailleurs
d'ailleurs mais dans des endroits où ils
sont bien isolés et là c'est les
nourrices qui prennent la relève ces
fameuses nourrissent elles sont
sélectionnées comment c'est pas
n'importe qui alors aussi il y a toute
une histoire les nourrices qui sont
sélectionnés selon le rang social et les
qualités physiques quand même donc on a
les deux ensemble il faut et en plus la
question de la nourrice c'est qu'il faut
qu'elle ait le lait qui soit adapté à
l'âge de l'enfant et ça c'est pas
toujours évident parce que là j'ai le
lait évolue en fonction de l'âge de
l'enfant et c'est comme ça que Louis XIV
par exemple parce qu'il y a un
changement de nourrice trop fréquent
dauphin les enfants de Louis XIV il aura
quand même eu 6 il est resté que le
dauphin c'est-à-dire l'aîné à cause de
ça parce qu'ils ont changé trop
fréquemment du nourrice et qu'elle
n'avait pas le lait qui correspondait
trop riche elle est trop riche c'est le
début on leur donne peut-être enfin bon
bref mais eux ils le savaient ou le
savaient pas qu'il fallait faire
attention à ça alors il le savait mais
ils ont pas toujours les nourrices qu'il
faut et puis bon c'est pas la seule
raison pour laquelle les enfants sont
morts mais c'est vrai que le changement
nourriss fréquent n'a pas aidé parce que
les choix de nourrissons aussi
politiques on prend pas n'importe qui et
que donc en fait il y avait des tensions
à la cour pour placer telle ou tel
épouse capable de nourrir l'enfant royal
qui est le même aura refourgué son
nourrisson
c'est un élevage intensif si je peux
permettre c'est un peu comme les
élevages de chèvres il faut un bébé tous
les tous les ans pour pouvoir les traire
l'année
sauf que c'est un élevage qui est pas
toujours intensif c'est le problème des
reines de France quand elles n'ont pas
le but ce serait que ça soit intensif le
rêve le mieux c'est que ce soit en fait
le but c'est même pas que ce soit
intensif le but c'est que les enfants
soient viable cette année la monarchie
fait beaucoup d'enfants si j'ose dire
parce qu'elle a besoin d'avoir des
réserves d'héritiers voilà c'est ça et
sachant que les enfants sont fragiles il
faut en avoir le maximum voilà alors je
me disais et pas que des garçons
d'ailleurs non parce que comme vous
dites c'est bien les femmes c'est ce
sont des des outils pour faire des
alliances très important ça ils le
disent toujours ils disent au moment des
mariages par exemple on espère ils
disent à la reine on espère Votre
Majesté que vous donnerez beaucoup
d'enfants fille et garçon il faut les
laisser pour assurer la succession et
les filles pour assurer les alliances et
ça c'est les filles c'est essentiel et
d'ailleurs on le voit bien parce que les
reines conservent quand les filles elles
sont mariées à 12 14 ans elle s'installe
c'est à ce moment là puisqu'elles sont
mariées à des rois étrangers mais les
reines comme Catherine de Médicis elle
suit de très très près la grossesse les
accouchements de sa fille de sa fille
qui est devenue reine d'Espagne ou de
l'autre d'ailleurs qui est duchesse de
Lorraine elle fait très attention à ça
parce que là aussi on retrouve la
question politique c'est que du coup
derrière il y a la procréation en
Espagne d'héritier qui fortifie la
couronne ou pas et la position de la
reine en Espagne comme comme d'ailleurs
voilà et revenons à la dernière évoquée
dans votre livre va savoir
Marie-Antoinette qui quand même assure
le dos sa mère Marie-Thérèse de triche
qui elle a eu 16 enfants alors elle dit
vous dites qu'elle dit moi je ne fais
pas de guerre je fais des alliances
parce qu'elle Marie ses enfants donc
très bien ça évite des guerres
et elle harcèle un peu sa fille de
courrier elle est avide d'informations
et du coup marie-Antoinette est un peu
traité d'espionneutritionne voilà le la
difficulté pour une reine tant qu'elle a
pas d'enfants c'est pour ça aussi que
les enfants c'est vraiment politique
c'est que la difficulté qu'elle a c'est
tant qu'elle a pas d'enfants on a
soupçonne de pas être complètement
française une fois qu'elle a des enfants
en fait elle se elle se consacre enfin
c'est l'idée au moins qu'on s'en fait
elle se consacre à l'intérêt de ses
enfants donc à l'intérêt de la dynastie
je comprends elle est un peu louche quoi
et voilà tant qu'elle en a pas on la
soupçonne de rester encore une étrangère
et Marie-Antoinette pauvre ça devait
être atroce c'est huit années c'est
vraiment le cas c'était assez huit ans
sans enfanter vous rendez compte après
c'est arrivé plusieurs fois
on prend quatre nombreux Médicis 10 ans
sans enfanter aussi après elle en a eu
10 en disant donc elle a compris Anne
d'Autriche 22 sans avoir d'enfant et des
enfants qui arrivent in extremises et
puis on a des reines qui n'en n'ont pas
eu du tout comme comme Louise de
Lorraine l'épouse de François Henry III
bon bref c'est pas des vies faciles non
et surtout il y a pas d'affectif on a
l'impression que c'est normal on se dit
tiens elles sont dures elles n'ont pas
de cœur et tout mais pas du tout elle
peut-être qu'elle se protège aussi pas
question de s'attacher ou même une mère
qui aurait des filles elles savent que
les filles vont partir on va pas
s'attacher à une fille qu'on vous enlève
à 12 ans enfin et puis de toute façon
elle les élèvent pas donc elle les
connaît plus tant que les enfants alors
ce qu'elle connaît le mieux c'est ce
qu'elle ramène à la cour quand elle
devient
renverse et irrégente ce que fait un peu
Catherine de Médicis parce qu'elle elle
fait revenir ses filles à la cour mais
elle les filles repartent parce qu'elles
sont mariées très jeunes par contre les
garçons elle les a pendant très
longtemps voilà Louis XIV pareil il
grandit en fait dans l'ombre de sa mère
pendant
qu'elle est très et ça forme une somme
de couple finalement on l'arrêt de mère
et le et le futur et le roi et le roi et
le roi va sur et futur régnant quand il
est jeune et alors elle est restée oui
elle est restée oui finalement c'est la
femme de pouvoir c'est la femme de
pouvoir au sein de la famille ça de la
famille sur son fils sur son fils et
donc sur les autres par euh sur les
enfants concomitance et est-ce que vous
croyez pas que la vie finalement de
Madame Elisabeth la sœur de Louis XVI
qui allait rester célibataire c'était
pas ce qu'il y avait une mieux à faire à
l'époque à part qu'elle soit morte la
pauvre décapitée mais
par rapport à ce rang
elle a une vie tranquille par rapport à
toutes ces femmes non c'est du haut ce
que je dis non elle a pas une vie
tranquille parce que en fait elle est
aussi extrêmement contrainte à parler
les règles de la courbe
personne à la paix dans la famille en
fait personne n'a la paix dans des
sociétés ou la place et déterminer le
rang doit être défendu les enjeux de
pouvoir sont permanents donc c'est c'est
que tensions et haine et violence tout
est tension mais tout n'est pas que n
est violence mais beaucoup mais c'est
comme les milieux politiques actuels
c'est des tensions mais il y a pas que
ça aussi il n'y a pas d'enfants en jeu
actuellement il y a pas d'enfants en jeu
encore que le placement des héritiers ça
c'est autre chose mais il y a pas
nécessairement d'enfants en jeu mais là
les enfants
sont sont des sons à la fois des enjeux
et des éléments qui sont extérieurs au
couple royal je comprends et c'est
justement alors vous allez dire que
c'est ma petite chouchoute mais
Marie-Antoinette c'est quand même elle
qui a commencé un petit peu à se
rebeller en exigeant
d'allaiter son premier enfant en ayant
auprès d'elle ses enfants ce qui se
faisait pas comme vous le disait tout à
l'heure ça a été un peu la mort c'est
une nouvelle façon de d'être pour ces
familles royales non c'est aussi
l'évolution du XVIIIe voilà l'évolution
du 18e il faut le voir déjà avec Marie
lexinska là à l'épouse de Louis XV en
fait elle demande à avoir un appartement
privé à garder ses enfants auprès d'elle
elle elle se rebelle un peu quand Louis
XV décide d'envoyer les filles au
couvent même les gens regardent
certaines
on voit ensuite le dauphin son fils avec
sa second épouse qui qui reste à la
maison qui s'occupe des enfants etc donc
Marie on commence à bouger tout ça ça
bouge et Marie-Antoinette de la elle
valorise la maternité qui en plus dans
son cas est triomphante parce qu'elle
arrive tard 8 ans plus tard voilà Fanny
on pourrait dire encore plein de choses
parce que ce sujet absolument
passionnant donc j'encourage tout le
monde à lire ce livre on apprend
vraiment ces histoires des femmes aussi
quelque part et et on vous retrouve au
salon du livre et merci à très bientôt
j'espère pour un autre ouvrage au revoir
à tous merci de nous avoir suivi pour ce
VIP à bientôt
[Musique]